今日はあずみ車場です
するぜええ
観光とか一つで有名な今回カール伊沢に来
ております
[音楽]
見てくださいこの木木木木というかも機
しかないんですけども1機器
あらゆる部分が黄すべて向きなんですけど
も結構言えばキャンプとかゴルフ場とから
有名なんですけども軽井沢今回なんと何度
ですよ犬スケベさなんすか
日本最大中の
キャンピングカーを見つけました
ここにあるん
らしいよなんかキャンピングカーってよく
あるじゃないですかああいうやつに裏切ら
もう見てこれキャンピングカー
今結構なんかスタンダードなサイズ等せる
キャンペーンのかズームでかいけどね
分かるんですよなんかふと僕を被ったん
ですよキャンピングカーのデカいサイズ
ってどうなってんだろうといろいろ調べた
結果こちらに日本最大級レベルの超巨大な
キャンピングがあるということで今日は
米件数ですよけどあんまり俺キャンピング
カーてるかとしたりした強化ないんです
けども編しょうがねぎなり最大級覚え
ちゃった俺 em 味を買い家であるか皮
はもう普通のサイズもどれだけだって
しまいもしれませんがせっかくなので最大
10サイズを見たいということでおめ早速
日本最大級のキャンピングカー見て行き
たいと思います息は出勤制キャンピング
カー乗ったことあるうないすごく
がチャッキー行け時代がキャンピングカー
からどういう事よもうすごいよ見て行う
いいですねぇー o 4 c ですよ
ございますいいえ
誰がトップだ俺
黒いけどさ
うぇいうぇーい付おっとり挫折た迫った
けど光ってナイスッと行けこの本遠くにも
今回の我々のキャンピングカーあるらしい
のであげてみますね
で泊まれると思いますと泊まれるらしいよ
いくぜ
同同同同正面から見るとまるで海でも
でかい
でかいよっこいったからもうちょいこっち
できますね
見ます
バッケンのん
これか
ってから作ったのかさー
いやんでみたいになってるんだもうこれが
日本最大級のはキャンピングカー動いなぁ
いやで会はバスだバスです何こっちに来た
多く下がるよ大きくないうって来
すごい夜行バスの沖からこれ大きいは
大きい住むし早速中へ入ってみましょう
さっきのあの大きさなキャンペーンが
スタンダードだとしたらまーぢでー会議を
行きますね
プレイします
[音楽]
くださ
ほど来た来た来たとエッ
空港やあ違ったなんだっけ空港うん彼らの
やつ名前
飛行機な
飛行機の設置みたいなのがあるう
ちょっと入ってみていいですかを目指し
ます
すごいすごいすごいどんくらいすごいです
か
これ見てるここからユース悟空小屋を飛行
機ですね空港への飛行機すっここだけ見る
とはね飛行機のビジネス比べたらさんです
ねこちらこれですよいいなぁみてください
これもういう行カードおっしろと言わん
ばかりせこいねー
るっぽいな大収納
収納多いですね中の多いておくだすげー
めっちゃついてるんだけど
うわぁ凄い凄い
どうぞ
ブーブーキャンピングカーか
アティ道を全部キャンペーン
ヌーそれでちょっと飽きられちゃったん
ですけどね yes モンコレ言えねぇ
結局
これだけ雑魚の車終わらないですよ十分い
えじゃあもうもうもうもう
ここから
この部屋
広がるらしいですムービーがわかりません
僕はで室ておりてが広げるらしいんです
けども特別に許可をいただいてこのまま
キロ下でもらえるらしいのでちょっと見て
みましょうか
これより大きくなるん
ちょっとツって車も大きくなったようです
ここの部屋が外に飛びれる感じです
ちょっと見たいねする出せばいい
動いで動いてる
結構いきますねー
うわぁ
ありがとうございます
部屋に振っ
さっきはちょっと通路狭いなーとか思って
たんですけどこれが真の姿かいやーすご
すごいよとプレゼン目隠しされてさあここ
連れてこられてたって離されから車だと
思うホテルだと思う間違いなくそういう
わけで計算を取ったこれ相当広くなったよ
すごいはさっきの佐世保やってる時は
さーん
大きいですねぐらいだったんですけど今
王子言い方が変わったこれで皆さん車の中
ですよこれ釣り身長高い1-186でも
つかないから高さも十分あるんだろうね
確かに車の中歩いてるて来られてやばい
ですよねやばいやばいと広がった時車どう
だっているのはすぎて苦しくん
[音楽]
すごい見て見て見て
鳥ってっちゃうってやつようにウィーンで
伸びてやなかった大きくなっはいだけで
今日はシリーズキャンピングカーで生活と
いうことでいきましょう健介いやーいい
わー
えちょうどいいサイズかふーんベッドを
組み立ててもう一個作れるんだようすごい
者2人目れるんだ長を経てますてれば誘い
甲山寺ば逃げ出しちゃうよ今日はここで
バーベキューだねーいいねーまじで休憩し
ましょう雪グリできますから
お疲れ様です
dea
線される
ブーブー
ワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
何1 a バレーでしたりですねうんか
もって感じです
ね bar ズってたじゃないですか
結菜さんねっ
うっ今日は3人で約実家で過ごしましょう
どうよじゃあ家みたいなねやばいよね入っ
汁うちもここだけ見たらリビング処分ここ
で何か酒と飯食いたいしてでしょ
姉さんに寝れるかどうかもんだよそろそろ
最高他の所もあるから誰か一瞬ねっっ
絶対ここで3人で寝るっ
受け手芸画材皆様なんだヤリザ
イチャイチャなんだよ俺カメラ中から
ていん
[音楽]
oe 4 e 8 ee 柔らかい者えっ
これ全然 stage 言ってこの頃59
風呂しかも全然荒れるのかいい
ちょうどいいですねちょうど一さん入る
スペースアップ500今日これ322の森
へうわキタコレ
[音楽]
05アムウェイを
3点一環にも今ソーナー県民具が出えへん
なのにいると言ってもやっぱ外で
バーベキューも今展開してるんでん
再構成
一作はめていきましょうか
声をよ良いおいどこでも増えるという
やっぱ的なキャンピングが3日まいんたー
ばやっぱりありがとうございます
[音楽]
はい奪われます大穴に全部
bluetooth です
2個これさぁ皆さんえっやっちゃいます
じゃあちょっと涼子おもしろあれじゃあ
埋まるぞうまそう
ちょっと髪淫液を付け下さい
またここに声ね行っただけ
やってりゃいいまず章6 a 4 a 5
a のふっ
うめーなんなえっつまだ取れねー幸せて
いるんまず
決まっですいやいや決まったらが頭にあっ
あっすまんだあー
えーる自動車道した月光よっ
を
good 勝10敗ああああああああねぇ
ウェザーのホゾおいしい5歳のでるだけな
のだけど骨月ひどいこれはレッスンだった
母うわぁストアねはーいざけんないつもと
かです
そうでふっくらですよねっ
使ってたらどうする
戦います
いった関係性組成物まで散歩戦います舌だ
から結構な時間をかけて
遅いアセスに回答だからこの毛をもう
ちょっと外の名 campfire すごい
イヤイヤなわけないですよこの俺はもうね
19年いろんな景色を見てきたこのを連に
エボいってはくるのは相当なげなことだと
2っておるんか
タイマーもポリテクですね
まぁ夜だからまあこんなもんですよね
まあまあも
セキュリティですかね
にすごい
me
でもいねえ
音もいいねやっちゃってこれキャンピング
カーの動画なん
キャンパスでもうキャップ黒山奥で風が
無いのはた日本人なんかあれ炎と森の
カーニバルですじゃあ最高上げて最後これ
がキャンピングカーか
さあやったことで寝る強度で
はず目までね
もう
この場で寝ます
始めた小銭はいおやすみなさい
おや炭失礼しますでしょうってしまっ
た失敗になるね大丈夫
倉持
ませんはったん
[音楽]
[拍手]
dice
e a
f
です
# e 4波で
[音楽]
違ってちょ